and then yeah what what else do we want
to talk about kingdom uh i haven't read
kingdom i've been i'd rather bring it
i've read the first five volumes of
kingdom because i read it it's long
right uh it's 60 volumes it's it's like
okay okay it's still going
it's still good okay okay okay i
remember because i remember when i was
like trying to get new manga to read i
was just like
[ __ ] you know this has 500 chapters i'm
just like
for [ __ ] sake right um and then i read
the first 100 chapters in like two days
and i'm like thank [ __ ] god this has
500 chapters it was it was like one of
those manga when i'm just like i'm so
glad that there is just like an infinite
number of chapters
it's not that that i dread it's that i
dread that i literally can't do anything
else like i can't watch anything i can't
read anything else i love that i'm like
that's that's the feeling i'm constantly
looking for because i love the feeling
of just being so absorbed into this
manga or anime or something that i
literally can't get on with my life
unless i
unless i'm finishing this thing because
like that that to me is like pure
enjoyment right and kingdom gave me that
for like a good like month i i only i
only had time just a month
i lost a month of my life i think and it
was like the best month ever i only read
like the first five volumes of it
because i was like at a manga cafe just
like chilling waiting for a friend or
whatever and i had to leave i was like
no i'm not leaving yeah i need i need to
continue reading this is [ __ ] insane
yeah so so like so like to give the to
give a brief like sell yeah
um so it's like when china was like
fragmented into different different
kingdoms
you see
you see what they did there were three
kingdoms yeah um no it was uh i think
this one has seven kingdoms right and so
it's the story of it's just it's just an
epic basically it's it's the very
definition of an epic where it's just
the story of uh so one one like there
was there's one farm boy shin who's the
main character and by complete chants he
meets um he meets one of the future
kings of the kingdom that he's living in
right
and throughout the entire history of
china no one's been able to unite all of
the kingdoms no one's been able to like
take over everything and just unite
everyone and so it's very simple it's
just the basic story of the king growing
up to be a king and uniting everyone and
it's the farmer who the farm boy who
grows up literally as a peasant
and uh it's his story of becoming the
greatest general
uh of china it's basically if you took
the golden age arc of berserk and just
made it in epic yeah
that sounds good
which is awesome because the golden asia
was [ __ ] awesome i love the golden
age yeah like imagine the golden age arc
but um
the biggest to me the biggest selling
point of kingdom is the battles
this man's drawing over here
he can't contain his love for kingdom
thinking about it
yeah i just want to talk about kingdom
okay
so i have never seen
any
other piece of media
depict warfare in as much detail as i
have kingdom right
because there's only like there's it's
been 500 chapters and one single battle
can easily take up like 50 to 100
chapters
yeah it's like lord of the rings yeah i
mean it's it's battle for helms deep
here yeah yeah yeah yeah literally like
imagine every battle imagine if that was
just every battle right but it's [ __ ]
ins it's actually [ __ ] insane go for
it are we close to finishing the story
no
[Music]
that puts me off because i i don't want
to get into something where i'm going to
be like 50 years old and i'm like hey
son uh my my favorite manga is finishing
kingdom literally every one piece fan
but like but it's it's it's one of those
manga where it's it's such a simple kind
of it's it well it's it's simple and
it's not right because obviously there's
a lot of there's a lot of like politics
involved there's a lot of like
intricacies into how they basically try
to take over their kingdom because
there's i really can't condense it down
into like whenever i'm going it's an
epic yeah it is an episode
but like it's because it's broken up
into like different arcs you can just
read one arc and you just you can just
like stop it it's kind of
you can take a breather like i literally
binge one arc then binge another arc and
then binge another because i'm just like
i just want to see what happens at the
end of this battle and it's it depicts
what like i said it depicts warfare in a
better way than i've ever seen in any
other market because like you know
you know how they like try to write
smart characters in a lot of fiction
whereas you to to write a smart
character you have to make the other
character dumb right so there's been so
many like there's been so many like
warfare kind of scenes where it's just
like they they introduce this like
really smart general or something and
it's because he sees a strategy that the
other general doesn't see and it's like
to the reader it's the most obvious
[ __ ] strategy of all time we're gonna
go around the back yeah holy [ __ ]
they'll never know if they flank them to
the right yeah exactly and and with
kingdom the reason it takes like about
like 50 to 100 chapters per battle is
because it's they're pretty 5d chess
they are like it's it's it's so
incredible to see so many styles of
generals battling against each other
because it's it is literally like
watching two gm's play against each
other and no it i i'm absolutely serious
because like you're you're turning the
page and you like both both sides are
making moves both sides are like taking
pieces they're taking rooks they're
taking bishops it is kind of like
watching a chess game except it's
because it's a battle it's not just it's
not just all about strategy sometimes
you have people who [ __ ] flip the
board and there's and then there's
nothing you can do about that just
because they're too powerful and there
are some people who knows that this guy
is someone who is going to flip the
board and he takes that into account and
so
the winner of the battle isn't the
person is isn't the person who's like
necessarily dumber it's just the person
who maybe thinks that extra half step
ahead and you really don't know until
you turn like the final few pages of an
arc how it's going to turn out the
author must have like [ __ ] binge read
like the art of war like
honestly just like honestly i've only
heard like the most insane i'd like
to be like the other like those reviews
yeah yeah
five stars yeah like my work like
with it without spoil without spawning
it's like some of the best moments of
this manga like i think with this
this uh this manga has an arc which is
one of my favorite arcs of like all of
manga and that's that's because it's
like it's an arc without spawning the
exact plot points it's an arc where you
have like [ __ ] five six generals all
of them have like are making fun playing
5d chess with each other making moves
against each other and you're just like
holy [ __ ] i can't even keep up with the
amount of strategies going on and the
different pieces like that that are
being pushed around it's absolutely
[ __ ] insane it's so big brain that i
really cannot explain
again ever since i read those five
volumes of kingdom i've been this close
to just been saying focus and just
buying the rest of the volume is it
published weekly
okay that's good that's good it's
probably there's no way they're gonna
get to five dollars i've just given up
the hope on manga where they're like
okay now we're publishing monthly am i
all right and i'm never gonna read it
because it's never gonna finish yeah if
you if you wanna see like the brain
expands me more of just like of just
reading something that is just like
super smart without making making it
like seem pretentious or something yeah
and the artist
i think someone asked uh i don't know
who it was
the question was like if you're not
smart how do you write smart characters
if you're not smart yourself how do you
write a smart camera yeah yeah like
legit i'm just yeah i still i remember
they answered something but even me i
was thinking about i i don't know how
you would how would you because you
would know what smart is because yeah
yeah so yeah it's like i think this is
this one is this what smart people are
like yeah it's like how do you ask your
smartphone how do you write a smart
character who's like 300 iq when you're
not 300 iq yeah
yeah
what i would
what i would uh guess is that
they are uh the author of this must have
just studied so many like history
historic battles because some of like
the taxes and strategies that can they
come up with this is just like it's 300
iq versus 302 iq and it's just like it's
just like that extra two iq that gives
them the edge in battle it's porn that
matters yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly it's
uh it's it's such a good absolutely i'm
sold yeah it's fun
to head to the [ __ ] list
if you want something that is just an
incredible epic read kingdom